[Musique]
merci beaucoup à tous les cinq monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres monsieur le commissaire au
plan mesdames messieurs les
parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs à vos grades
d'égalité
chers amis
merci d'être d'être aujourd'hui à
l'elysée pour ce moment un peu
particulier d'abord parce qu'on va
essayer de se projeter loin dans un
moment où beaucoup nous qu'on couvre
concours en quelque sorte à nous faire
regarder à côté
je pense que c'est une d'abord une bonne
vertus
personnel mental et c'est aussi très bon
pour un pays comme le nôtre
merci parce que à travers vos cinq
prises de parole vous avez illustré des
convictions qui sont vos convictions
personnelles mais vous avez un peu aussi
rendu compte de tout le travail qui a
été fait par celles et ceux que vous en
êtes des contributrices et contributeur
dans cette salle qui ont préparé depuis
des mois cette stratégie ce travail
collectif et donc étudiantes et
étudiants chercheuse chercheurs
universitaires
responsables d'organisations de branches
professionnelles syndicales
entrepreneuse entrepreneurs
investisseurs
parlementaire est évidemment les
ministres qui ont piloté ce travail je
les en remercie avec l'ensemble des
grands organismes de recherche et notre
politique économique et industrielle
ce que je vais essayer ici ce dont je
vais essayer de rendre compte est un peu
le fruit de votre travail collectif
de notre travail collectif comme nation
nous sommes confrontés à des défis qui
ne sont pas neufs
on les voit poindre depuis maintenant
quelques quelques décennies ils sont en
train de se de se consolider de se
raffermir et ils ont en quelque sorte
présidé à ce que la france comme
l'europe ou fait ces dernières années ce
qui porte notre conviction collective et
ce qui a été encore affirmé conforter
pendant là pendant la crise et que le
rapport d'ailleurs que j'avais commandé
il ya quelques mois monsieur blanchard
et tyrol avec un collectif d'économistes
à pucon fut confirmée
nous la planète est confrontée à
quelques grands défis
inédit dans leur concentration et leur
convergence un premier grand défi vous
l'avez tous rappelé je crois que
maintenant il ya un consensus sur ce
sujet c'est évidemment le défi
climatique environnementale c'est à dire
le problème à la fois des dérèglements
climatiques
et de la raréfaction de la biodiversité
c'est un défi profond qui changent
évidemment
nos moyens de produire de produire
d'abord de l'énergie de faire de
l'industrie de nous déplacer de
consommer de nous alimenter et donc qui
nous conduit à complètement repenser nos
modes d'organisation collective
pour autant il faut continuer à faire
tout ce que je viens de dire
d'évidence et il faut d'autant plus le
faire que la planète elle continue à
grandir le deuxième grand défi il a été
aussi éclairé par le plan dans un
rapport récent c'est le défi
démographique il est colossal c'était
souvent et ça a été ces dernières
décennies un peu un impensé de nos
politiques publiques mais ce défi
démographique il a plusieurs composantes
c'est d'abord l'augmentation du nombre
d'habitants sur la planète
je paye ici
reconvoquée des thèses malthusiennes
qu'on connaît depuis longtemps dans fins
est un fait quand on a de la ressource
naturelle qui se raréfie d'attention sur
différents sujets différents écosystèmes
on a une planète dont la population
croît mais elle croit si je puis dire
très différemment et donc nos sociétés
sont confrontées un vieillissement
démographique et dans beaucoup de nos
pays même si la france a longtemps mieux
résisté que d'autres à une chute de sa
natalité et al'inverse à une explosion
démographique dans d'autres pays et donc
à la pression des grandes migrations
ces deux grandes défi d'ailleurs se
renforcent l'un l'autre car les défis
migratoires trouvent aussi leurs sources
dans les déséquilibres climatique que
certaines régions connaissent
aujourd'hui tout cela se tient mais ce
deuxième défi démographique est très
important ce qu'ils déstabilisent là
aussi nos modes d'organisation en
société le temps que nous passons au
travail par rapport au temps que nous
passons à nous former puis à vivre plus
âgés ensuite et essayer de vieillir dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
le mode de financement de nos modèles
sociaux etc etc et crée beaucoup de
tensions aussi entre différentes régions
du monde par les migrations
le troisième grand défi que nous sommes
tous en train de vivre c'est le défi des
inégalités parce qu'il faut pas le
négliger il est bien pointé par et
beaucoup d'économistes qui sont ici
l'ont montré
au fond depuis le xviiie siècle nos
sociétés démocratiques reposant sur
l'économie sociale de marché avaient une
forme de consensus qui était concret de
la valeur mais il y avait toujours un
progrès constants
nos enfants vivraient mieux que nous ça
c'est à peu près constamment vérifier
avec l'exception terrible et historique
des guerres mais quelque chose est en
train de s'enrayer dans notre système
qui est un dérèglement
l'organisation du
notre économie mondiale
l'explosion des déséquilibres en
particulier au sein de nos économies par
deux phénomènes l'hyper financiarisation
d'une part mais peut-être encore plus
ces dernières années
l'accélération des technologies
numériques
est ce qu'on appelle la digitalisation
maintenant qui est un formidable levier
d'innovation mais est aussi un levier
d'accélération
des en quelque sorte de l'écartement de
nos sociétés avec des modèles comme le
nôtre qui sont très protecteurs et il
faut s'en féliciter j'y reviendrai mais
que nous avons plutôt conçus comme des
modèles qui venait corriger les
inégalités qui se forge est là où le
système en quelque sorte est en train de
les produire de plus en plus vite et
écarte les destinées individuelles de
plus en plus vite
ce qui est un vrai défi
tout ça est en train de créer une série
de chocs des chocs démocratique dans nos
sociétés
liées en quelque sorte au doute que ces
crises sont ces grands défis sont en
train de créer dans nos sociétés quand
la manière de produire de s'alimenter
est faite de tensions permanentes on le
voit bien dans nos sociétés quand on est
angoissé sur la manière de vieilli quand
les inégalités sont en train d'augmenter
qu'on ne voit plus les perspectives on a
un doute démocratique qui s'installe
toutes les sociétés démocratiques sont
en train de le vivre
nous avons à côté de ça un choc
géopolitique qui en est la conséquence
parce que quand il ya de la rareté sur
les ressources quand il ya de la
concurrence exacerbée sur les modes
d'innovation quand en quelque sorte ce
sont des modèles qui jouent leur survie
ou lors leur hégémonie sacré de la
tension géopolitique
et puis évidemment tous a aussi créé une
forme de choc anthropologique parce que
la transformation la révolution des
usages liés en particulier au numérique
créé un changement profond de notre
manière de nous organiser en société
d'imaginer de vivre les émotions de
communiquer les informations
c'est le monde dans lequel nous vivons
je leur pose là en début parce que on
peut pas penser la france 2 de 2030
l'europe de 2030 essayer de voir la
dynamique qu'on peut prendre sur la
décennie si on ne prend pas comme comme
départ ces grandes tendances qui sont là
mais qui sont en train de s'accélérer
est ce que la crise que nous venons de
vivre que dont nous l'espérons
collectivement dont nous sortons la
pandémie de covile 19 a en quelque sorte
remis en cause ces grands défis ces
grandes transformations non au contraire
elle les a plutôt conforté
mais je pense que nous nous devons
collectivement d'essayer de tirer aussi
quelques leçons de cette endémie
qui sont importantes pour penser là
aussi la france de 2030
la pandémie elle nous a fait toucher du
droit d'abord notre vulnérabilité
nous nous sommes rappelés et c'est très
cohérent avec les défis que je viens
d'évoquer que nous appartenions à
l'ordre du vivant
et donc quelque chose qui se passe
quelque part à dix mille kilomètres de
nous peut-être entre
l'humain et l'animal
peut bloquer totalement la planète et
changer la face du monde et notre
organisation collective et donc la
première leçon que nous devons
collectivement tirer de ce qui s'est
passé c'est que nous en effet nous
sommes éminemment vulnérables et on ne
peut pas penser notre projection à 10 15
20 ans en quelque sorte comme si nous
n'étions pas dans le vivant de manière
purement technique comme si nous étions
assimilables à des tableaux de chiffres
à des équations à quelque chose qui
réductible nous avons cette
vulnérabilité
profonde
la deuxième chose c'est notre dépendance
vis-à-vis de l'étranger on avait voulu
l'oublier parce que nous vivions dans un
miracle mais dont nous avions là aussi
un peu oublié la fragilité c'était que
le monde était ouvert et que tout
circule et parfaitement et librement
je suis heureux de vous retrouver tous
avec des masques aujourd'hui je serai
encore plus heureux le jour où vous n'en
aurez plus ça voudra dire qu'on sera
totalement des débarrasser l'épidémie je
n'oublie pas qu'il ya 18 mois nous
étions tous soumis au manque de masques
personne ne pensait qu'on pourrait
manquer de masques c'était l'une des
choses qui avait le moins de valeur
ajoutée et d'ailleurs nous en avions
collectivement
implicitement parce que ça n'a jamais
été un choix assumé de la nation on en
avait délégué la production à des pays
qui produisait à beaucoup moins beaucoup
plus bas coûts que nous en disant c'est
pas important on en trouvera toujours
dépendance et expériences de la
dépendance qui peut être dramatique
parce que nous avons vu à ce moment là
quand il ya de la dépendance et qu'on se
retrouve dans des situations il ya plus
de coopération c'est le drame et donc on
ne peut plus penser nos économies de
systèmes de production comme si tout
était écrit pour que ça aille bien en
toutes circonstances nous devons donc
tirer cette leçon aussi de la crise qui
est que la dépendance choisi est
relative est une chose c'est des termes
de la coopération mais on doit rebâtir
les termes d'une indépendance productive
françaises et européennes parce que je
ne suis pas en train de dire qu'il
faudrait tout se mettra tout reproduire
en france nous ne serions pas le faire
enfin il faut qu'au niveau de l'europe
nous sachions reproduire ce dont nous
avons besoin pour aujourd'hui pour
demain
deuxième leçon de la crise qui n'était
pas un immédiat
troisième leçon de la crise c'est quand
même la force du modèle éducatif et
social français on a tenu parce que la
nation a décidé d'investir pour être
solidaire faux pas en sortie de crise
qu'on se mette à l'oublier en pensant
qu'on pourrait passer un autre monde
c'est une force inouïe
et on aura d'autres crises de manière
certaine et donc tout ce que nous devons
penser pour la france de 2030 doit
contribuer aussi à renforcer ce modèle
qui est un modèle à la fois productif et
solidariste je dirais
mais qui est important avec des
équilibres qu'il faut constamment
réajuster qui sont des choix
démocratiquement débattu et puis les
quatrième leçon de cette pandémie à mes
yeux c'est
que nous avons assisté à une
extraordinaire accélération de
l'innovation et j'y reviendrai sans
doute à plusieurs reprises ses skis
aussi pour moi a présidé au choix en
sortie de crise de vous proposer
collectivement et d'essayer de nous
projeter collectivement à 2030 c'est que
nous avons une fois encore mais là de la
manière peut être la plus vibrante
déjoué tous les pronostics scientifique
moi je n'oublie pas fait toujours être
lucide sur ses propres
défauts et les choses qu'on a parfois
c'est de manière approximative il ya à
peu près un an j'expliquais à nos
compatriotes mois les spécialistes me
disent il ya très peu de chances qu'on
est un vaccin avant la fin de l'année
c'était vraiment ce que les spécialistes
me disait parce qu'on ne disait jamais
dans l'histoire de l'humanité on a
trouvé un vaccin en un an de temps
jamais arrivé ce qui était vrai on l'a
fait et il ya eu dans les dernières
semaines de l'année 2020 une
accélération exceptionnel je pense que
tous ceux qui l'ont vécue s'en
souviennent où on a d'un seul coup
écrasé tous les délais et donc la
quatrième leçon de la crise pour moi
c'est que l'innovation est une source de
solutions pour mieux vivre pour projeter
une nation un continent est peut-être le
monde entier vers des solutions qui sont
bonnes pour l'humanité
mais que
en quelque sorte les contraintes de
l'innovation jusqu'à présent dans
lesquels on vivait sont en train de
changer par une forme d' accélération de
compression du temps d'accumulation des
moyens qui peuvent être mis à un moment
donné si on considère que cette
innovation est une innovation qui peut
tout changer et à ce moment là c'est
assez simple vous êtes dedans vous êtes
jerry c'est la cinquième leçon de la
crise il faut s'en féliciter c'est qu'on
a su recréer de la coopération
internationale et européenne pour rester
dedans parce que soyons lucides sur nous
même si nous n'avions dépendu que de ce
que la france aurait produit je le dis
pour tous ceux qui prient qui plaide le
nationalisme excessif la france ne
produit pas de vaccin et le produit
toujours pas de vaccin et red messager
et donc c'est parce qu'on a su
participer à la coopération
internationale qui a eu cette
compression de l'innovation
extraordinaire grâce à des très grands
scientifiques français travaillant à
travers le monde mais qu'on a su ensuite
recréer de la coopération pour acheter
et reproduire en europe et le distribuer
à nos compatriotes et sa c5 leçons de la
crise et il faut pas les laits perte de
vue quand on veut se projeter une fois
que j'ai dit ça on voit bien qu'on est
dans un monde qui est en rupture
profonde et au fond dans l'une des
grandes caractéristiques que nous ne
devons pas oublier ce qui fait notre
force
on doit être lucide sur nos faiblesses
parce qu'elles peuvent être encore plus
cruel demain quel nom était fière parce
que c'est un endroit où tout s'accélère
on est dans l'innovation de rupture où
le gagnant 30 ou sur beaucoup
d'innovations et où on est et si on nous
nous retrouvons or de l'innovation on
peut perdre énormément
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que j'ai
souhaité
en cette sortie de crise
que nous nous projetons et qui se
travaille cet effet pu rendons ce tous
ces derniers mois par l'ensemble des
acteurs pour essayer de regarder quelles
sont nos forces les faiblesses et
surtout comment on pouvait se projeter à
l'horizon d'une décennie mais en fait au
delà mais il faut à 2030 se doter
d'objectifs parce que par rapport à tout
ça si je regarde notre pays nous avons
des vraies forces et des vrais atouts
par rapport à ces changements et c'est
ces grands défis et ses leçons de la
crise on a nous sommes un pays
extrêmement complet qui présent sur tous
les continents qui a une force
productive historique une capacité à
inventer qui est une grande puissance
agricole agro alimentaires industriels
créative
qui a su historiquement innover nous
sommes un pays créateur c'est dans notre
adn
nous sommes un pays dont le modèle
social à la fois éducatif est en
réparation des inégalités est une force
j'en suis convaincu compte tenu de tout
ce que je viens de dire est qu'on a
appris de la crise
mais à côté de ça on a des vraies
faiblesses
des vraies faiblesses nous avons ces
dernières décennies sous investis en
éducation formation enseignement
supérieur et recherche
on a commencé à corriger cela avec la
loi de programmation recherche et avec
les réinvestissements matière éducative
mais c'est un début de réparation mais
quand je regarde avec nos grands
comparables on a beaucoup d investir
quand on se compare nous sommes un pays
qui travaille moins que les autres en
quantité ça reste vrai et donc nous
avons une quantité de travail à louer
qui n'est pas au bon niveau à la fois
dans le cycle de vie en horaire cumulée
et au fond on a une force qui est notre
modèle social et éducatif on a une
faiblesse c'est qu'on n'a plus le modèle
productif qui permet de le financer
c'est ça notre grande incohérence moi je
ne crois pas qu'on arrivera à réduire
notre modèle pour notre modèle social
c'est très dur dans une démocratie de
dire aux gens on va vous enlever des
droits massivement ça n'existe pas on
peut améliorer les choses il faut
améliorer l'efficacité de la dépense
publique il faut permettre de rendre les
mêmes services avec moins d'argent ce
sont des modernisations qui prennent des
années mais si on veut projeter le pays
ce qui je crois profondément le le
destin français en continuant à protéger
même mieux protégés c'est à dire
prévenir les inégalités mieux formés
pour éviter les inégalités de destin
mais continuer à réparer les inégalités
produites par le système il nous faut
avoir un pays qui produisent davantage
c'est à dire un pays qui continue de
faire les réformes pour produire plus et
produire davantage ça veut dire un pays
qui retrouve aussi le fils du couple
innover produire parce que la production
de demain n'est pas celle d'hier est
donc par rapport à ce que je dis aussi
je suis convaincu que le levier
d'innovation est clé pour produire parce
qu'il faut là en la matière avoir
n'avoir aucune nostalgie il n'est pas
vrai que quand je dis on doit travailler
plus et produire plus on fera ni
l'agroalimentaire ni l'industrie et les
services
d'hier et encore moins ceux
d'aujourd'hui ils sont en train de se
transformer à marche forcée la question
c'est comment nous sommes à la pointe de
l'invention de ces derniers c'est le
seul moyen
en même temps qu'on saisit les défis que
j'évoque d'être à la hauteur du mal
français qui est notre truc triple
déficit déficit de croissance
potentielle déficit public déficit du
commerce extérieur ce triple déficit se
nourrit depuis des décennies
la clé pour y répondre c'est d'avoir une
stratégie macro économique d'innovation
industrielle qui permettent justement de
produire ces résultats alors par pas de
nulle part depuis un peu plus de quatre
années je crois qu'on essaie
profondément d'avoir une stratégie qui
répond d'abord à ce constat ces grandes
transformations et qui
je puis dire qu'il part de ce socle de
raisonnement et qui commence à produire
des résultats d'avant depuis quatre ans
transformé commencé à transformer notre
système éducatif
d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur de
d'apprentissage et de formation
professionnelle d'accès au travail
l'emploi on continue avec la réforme
assurance chômage on à réformer la
fiscalité du capital très profondément
et on a mis en place des réformes du
travail plus des réformes sectorielles
tout ça produit des résultats qui sont
très tangible et qui vont dans la bonne
direction
la france est redevenue depuis deux ans
le pays le plus attractif d'europe la
france recréer des emplois industriels
depuis deux ans qu'elle alors qu'elle en
détruisait depuis 2008 la france est
aujourd'hui en sortie de crise à un
niveau d'emploi qu'elle n'avait pas
connu depuis 15 ans et nous avons
atteint un niveau d'apprentis et
d'alternants que nous n'avions jamais
connu plus de 500000 malgré la crise je
paye fille égrainé les choses mais on
voit bien que les choses sont en train
de se transformer dans la bonne
direction qui est le fruit d'une
stratégie macroéconomique qui reposait
sur ces constats qui produit des
résultats et qui va dans la bonne
direction et il faut s'en féliciter faut
le consolider de la même manière on a
investi c'est bien réinvestir sur la
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
il ya des vraies réformes
organisationnelles qui sont portés par
nos universités nos organismes de
recherche le classement de shanghai est
ressorti cet été montrent qu'on est
quand même en train de revenir
complètement
dans la bataille donc les résultats sont
là ils sont dans la bonne direction et
ces résultats n'ont pas été fragilisées
par la crise parce que nous avons à la
fois eu un programme d'urgence pendant
la crise que le gouvernement apporte et
je l'en remercie puis un programme de
relance qui a été très coordonnée au
niveau européen plan de relance européen
et plan de relance français qu'il
déclinait qui a permis de consolider ses
résultats et même d'accélérer la sortie
de crise autour de trois piliers la
transition numérique la transition
écologique la cohésion sociale et
territoriale sont les 100 milliards
français dont 70 milliards sont déjà
engagés
dans ce cadre là nous avons même
commencé à tirer les leçons de la crise
tels que je les évoquer puisque le plan
france roll france relance est un plan
qui en accélérant les transitions qu'on
avait faits permet aussi de relocaliser
de rebâtir un début de souveraineté
on a une composante robotique on a une
composante
protéines qui est très importante et qui
est plébiscité par le monde agricole on
a une composante santé oms se remet à
reproduire du paracétamol en france
qu'on avait complètement abandonné ses
dernières années donc tout ça est
cohérent va dans la bonne direction et
le fruit je pense de d'un travail
consolidé durant ces dernières années
qui est celui du gouvernement des
parlementaires et de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes que vous êtes
néanmoins l'extraordinaire accélération
du monde que nous sommes en train de
vivre
conduite à penser que tout ce qu'on a
fait là mais pas suffisant et que si on
reste à ce rythme et à ce niveau
d'intensité
parce que nous avons aussi pris ses
décisions parfois quinze à vingt ans
après certains de nos voisins européens
nous ne rattraperons pas notre retard ou
surtout nous laisserons distancé dans
les 10 15 ans qui viennent
et donc fort des constats que je viens
d'évoquer de tout ce qui a été fait
qu'il va dans la bonne direction je
pense que la stratégie 2030 elle
s'impose aujourd'hui parce que en raison
des grands défis que j'évoquais est en
quelque sorte de cette sortie de crise
nous vivons une extraordinaire
accélération du monde de l'innovation
et des revenus
et cette accélération me conduit à
établir quelques convictions
fortes que je vis ici exprimer qu'ils
vont présider à cette stratégie
la première conviction c'est un peu le
fruit de ce qu'on a tous vécu pendant la
crise est-ce qu'on avait commencé à
vivre avant c'est au fond que
innovations de rupture innovations
technologiques et industrialisation sont
beaucoup plus liées qu'on ne l'a 28 est
jusqu alors
on avait dans nos débats politiques
intellectuels théorique souvent séparé
ces sujets
et je pense qu'il faut tirer le constat
que nous nous sommes trompés sur ce
point d'abord la france a longtemps
pensé qu'elle pouvait se
désindustrialiser en continuant à être
une grande nation nîmes d'innovation et
de production je crois que maintenant il
est établi que c'est faux quand on se
désindustrialise on perd de la capacité
à tirer de l'innovation dans l'industrie
et donc de l'innovation
même incrémentale et c'est celle ci qui
nourrit le dialogue avec l'innovation de
rupture c'est un continuum tout se tient
beaucoup plus que les débats ne l'avait
montré jusqu alors je parle ici sous le
contrôle d'économie industrielle qui
l'ont montré avant moi beaucoup mieux
que moi chez reli mais c'est la réalité
et donc je crois que maintenant c'est
établi et on l'a vécue parce que sur le
sur le plan de la santé nous avons
laissé notre tissu d'industrie
pharmaceutique
flétrir c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons
il faut bien le dire une innovation en
santé qui a perdu des rangs au niveau de
la compétition internationale et donc
c'est un continuum ci a pas de
d'industrie sciandri industrialis pas le
pays il est pas vrai qu'on pourra
redevenir une grande nation d'innovation
et même de recherche et aussi parce que
c'est ce qu'ont produit avec
l'innovation industrielle et ses
débouchés qu'on peut financer une
recherche fondamentale
ensuite tout ça est lié si je puis dire
dans l'autre sens parce que l'innovation
de rupture a complètement compris mais
son temps
entre l'invention et son
industrialisation et au fond
toute l'organisation internationale est
ainsi faite que l'ensemble des acteurs
partout dans le monde sont en
compétition instantanée pour en quelque
sorte réduire le temps qu'il y a entre
l'idée géniale et l'idée de rupture et
la possibilité pour que celle ci change
les pratiques et cela touche tous les
segments qui sont ici présents nos
grandes pharmas qui sont ici la nomme
nos grands groupes de métallurgie on le
sait et tout ça c'est une compression du
temps mais c'est aussi une accumulation
de capital et des batailles
et donc cette conviction est là un point
clé ça veut dire il faut qu'on vous même
en même temps la bataille de
l'innovation et de l'industrialisation
on peut pas choisir faut les mener
ensemble et ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on mettre beaucoup d'argent public et
privé parce que le gagnant prend tout
comme disent les anglo saxons
et donc c'est là où il ya une hyper
concentration du capital et des talents
que les choses se font et que vous êtes
dans la partie où que vous êtes sortis
de la partie et donc nos quantum
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas
donc ça c'est ma première conviction
très forte c'est qu'on doit vraiment
sortir de cette opposition recherche
fondamentale recherche incrémentale et
technologiques et industrialisation
massive essayez de comprimés tout ça ce
qui va avec c'est qu'il faut sortir de
deux de deux types d'oppositions qui
nous ont fait perdre beaucoup de temps
dans nos débats et qui sont qui sont
liées aussi à nos tempéraments parfois
ce que nous sommes les oppositions entre
les différents secteurs et disciplines
de recherche académiques ou autres les
frontières qui existe entre les sciences
humaines les sciences de gestion tout ça
est en train d'exploser totalement parce
que les cadres sont en train d'être
repensée on y reviendra mais le spatial
est un domaine où en même temps fait de
l'hyper technologies ont fait du
cantique des mathématiques des sciences
humaines du droit et où tout ça est en
train d'être convoqué très vite parce
que c'est un cadre qui est en train de
cette d'être repensé par cette
compression et la deuxième chose c'est
que l'opposition que j'entends encore
beaucoup dans nos débats publics entre
les start up et l'industrie
est une opposition du xxème siècle
elle est éminemment fausses
notre pays va se réindustrialiser par
des start up technologiques est ce qu'on
appelle le deep tech
et nos grands groupes industriels vont
survivre se transforme et gagner la
partie grâce à l'innovation de rupture
de start-up qu'ils auront un cube et où
qu'ils auront racheté ou avec lesquels
ils auront des partenariats ya pas de
france industrielle contre la france des
start up il n'y a pas de france des
start up qui soit qu'à paris dans
quelques bureaux de quelques
arrondissements tout ça est faux la
réalité de la france des start-ups et
une france qui est partout sur le
territoire et la réalité de la france
industrielle c'est qu'elle se nourrit
des start up et de la rupture
première conviction il faut tordre le
cou si je puis dire à des oppositions il
ya une compression de toutes ses
dimensions la deuxième conviction
qui est un peu sa conséquence c'est que
nous avons un besoin impérieux
d'accélérer les investissements publics
créateurs de croissance d'emploi et
d'indépendance industriels nous avons un
débat et nous devons continuer d'avoir
et il faut même le structurer sur la
dépense publique il est important et moi
je ne sais jamais pensé qu'on pouvait
construire l'avenir d'un pays à crédit
ou à découvert mais je pense qu'il ne
faut pas que ce débat nous conduisent à
faire d erreur profonde dans la nature
de dépenses publiques
et ça c'est extrêmement important
je crois que depuis quatre ans on a
montré qu'on savait consolider les
comptes publics sans détruire de la
croissance et en baissant même les
impôts ce qui est exactement la
trajectoire macroéconomique qui est
suivi depuis 2010 cette baisse
historique d'impôts pour les ménages
comme pour les producteurs
baisse avant crise de la dépense
publique récurrentes avec de la vraie
transformation et modernisation et donc
c'est la trajectoire pour moi qui ait du
sens mais dans ce temps d'accélération
il ne nous faut bâtir les termes d'une
crédibilité qui nous permettent
justement d' accélérer l'investissement
public dans l'innovation l'innovation de
rupture et la croissance industrielle
parce que c'est le seul moyen
dans le même temps de construire la
production et la croissance qui va nous
permettre de continuer à financer notre
modèle social et c'est le seul moyen de
construire les éléments de modernisation
sectorielle qui va nous permettre de
baisser la mauvaise dépense c'est à dire
la dépense curatives si nous ne prenons
pas ce virage de l'innovation
cette réalisation nous continueront de
dégrader nos déficits extérieurs parce
qu'on continuera de dépendre et
d'importer et nous continuerons de créer
trop peu d'emplois trop peu
d'opportunités pour nos jeunes et donc
de les réparer part de la dépense
publique en gros j'assume totalement un
pays qui investit dans la création de
nouvelles filières l'investissement et
l'apprentissage pour moins dépenser dans
l'assurance chômage et la réparation des
destins et c'est ce changement qui nous
faut faire et c'est maintenant qu'il se
joue parce que c'est maintenant que nos
filières existantes par une
modernisation profonde se transforme et
gagne la partie et c'est maintenant que
nous créons de nouvelles filières
et donc la clé c'est de comprendre aussi
en quelque sorte par rapport à tous nos
modèles et je parle des ch'ti sous
contrôle collectif de nos ministres ou
parlementaires eric et des autres qui
connaissent beaucoup mieux que moi tous
et tous ces sujets je vois et
parlementaires de commission des
finances des affaires économiques et qui
sont là en particulier
je pense que nous avons en quelque sorte
dans nos propres attendus en france
depuis trop d'années
intégrer une forme de sentiment de
défaite en considérant que la croissance
potentielle du pays était quelque chose
qui dont il était écrit qu'elle ne
changerait jamais
je pense qu'il nous faut réinvestir dans
une stratégie de croissance qui consiste
à dire en faisant des investissements
mais qui sont par leur gouvernance leurs
modalités totalement distinct de la
dépense récurrente
nous devons changer en profondeur les
termes de notre croissance potentielle
et augmenter la capacité de l'économie
française à croître par son innovation
par sa ré industrialisation par les
politiques de formation pour produire de
la richesse et donc se projeter vers son
avenir est dans le même temps rendre
soutenable son modèle social français
qu'elle doit continuer à moderniser et
rendre plus efficace
mais c'est le seul moyen d'arriver et
donc en quelque sorte je veux que nous
retrouvions
un cycle vertueux qui est innover
produire exporter et ainsi financer
notre modèle social et je pense que ce
modèle vertueux c'est celui qu'on peut
retrouver par un investissement massif
dans cette stratégie d'innovation et
d'industrialisation
qui doit venir en quelque sorte complété
mais en poussant beaucoup plus loin ce
qui a commencé d'être faits sur
l'éducation l'enseignement supérieur la
formation et l'investissement dans la
recherche car encore une fois ce que
nous avons fait ces deux dernières
années qui était très important avec la
loi de programmation et modification est
un élément de rattrapage que je ne sous
estime pas il faut maintenant porter une
stratégie qui est beaucoup plus dans la
rupture
partant de ces constats de ses
convictions est en quelque sorte de
cette ligne que je veux presser la
stratégie pour 2030 doit nous conduire à
investir 30 milliards d'euros pour
répondre justement à ce déficit le
déficit en quelque sorte de croissance
français
alors je vais pas ici dire que nous
allons être les leaders dans tous les
domaines nous devons être lucides sur
nos forces nos faiblesses
et je pense que
c'est pas parce qu'on le dit qu'on le
devient je crois à la capacité
performative certaines paroles mais je
suis aussi lucide sur le fait qu'on
parle là d'une compétition ouverte donc
faut simplement savoir
où on veut aller les moyens qu'on se
donne et les objectifs qu'on s'est signe
par contre je pense que nous devons dès
maintenant nous dire dans quels secteurs
et sur quels domaines nous pouvons être
en tête en 2030 en tant que français et
en tant qu'européen il ya quelques
secteurs ou très clairement nous pouvons
prendre le leadership
il ya aussi des secteurs où nous avons
pris des retards et où nous sommes
menacés
mais des secteurs que nous n'avons pas
le droit d'abandonner parce que si nous
les abandonnions en quelque sorte nous
construirons une dépendance laissons à
nos enfants un tissu économique qui fait
qu' il aurait plus est même question à
se poser est donc nous avons aussi des
secteurs à réinvestir parce qu'ils sont
stratégiques on doit se dire d'ici à
2030 on doit voilà
consolider nos parts de marché en
quelque sorte ne pas se laisser
décrocher et y en a d'autres nous
pouvons très clairement faire plus que
résisté et est dans le peloton de tête
c'est avec cet objectif que j'ai nous
avons collectivement bâtisse est cette
stratégie pour 2030 est la clé de tout
ça c'est notre indépendance et la
capacité à reprendre en main le destin
de la france et de l'europe
et au fond pourquoi faire tout cela
je crois qu'en tant que français et
français on a une petite idée nous
sommes pas le meilleur pays pour nous
adapter aux évolutions du monde quand on
nous dit il faut faire cette réforme
parce que les voisins l'ont fait ça
marche assez rarement en france n'avons
pas cette mentalité
gelé plusieurs fois dit assumant moi
même de l'être je suis le premier des
gaulois réfractaires nous n'aimons pas
quand on me dit vous souhaite pas bien
les choses et c'est ça marche jamais
chez nous bon par contre nous n'aimons
pas qu'on nous dise il faut faire ça
parce que les autres le font il va
falloir s'adapter mais nous n'aimons pas
perdre le contrôle de nos vies
individuelles et du destin de notre
nation c'est ça ce qui nous caractérise
je crois profondément et c'est
d'ailleurs constamment le message de la
france au monde et la promesse de la
france
c'est de défendre une forme d'humanisme
c'est de dire nous on a toujours choisi
on a choisi la liberté les lumières les
droits de l'homme l'exigence même quand
c'étaient des combats très difficile
nous avons résisté nous avons résisté
aux folies du monde même quand ça
paraissait
la vague dominante je crois que c'est ça
ce qui est en cause et ce qui est en jeu
pour 2030 et quand je dis bâtir notre
indépendance c'est vraiment de se dire
comment la france construit une
stratégie qui fait que nous pouvons
défendre l'humanisme dans lequel nous
croyons pour le siècle qui vient
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire bâtir cet
humanisme ça veut dire que compte tenu
des défis que je viens d'évoquer on voit
bien que nous devons
mieux produire nous voulons mieux vivre
on veut mieux comprendre le monde mais
on veut le faire à chaque fois au
service de nos valeurs et d'une certaine
une idée de l'humanisme qui est la nôtre
nous croyons au progrès
scientifique rationnelle
nous croyons que celui ci doit être au
service de l'humanité et que l'homme
doit jamais être en quelque sorte au
service d'un progrès technologiques qui
lui aurait
échappé deux idées très simple
mais si en quelque sorte nous bâtissons
toute notre stratégie là dessus je
dirais que l'objectif de la france de
2030 doit être cela
mieux produire mieux vivre mieux
comprendre le monde
en servant un humanisme français et
européen qui est le coeur de notre
message de notre promesse et ce que nous
avons encore à faire demain et donc en
construisant les voies et moyens de le
faire en étant plus indépendant en tant
que français et européens parce que si
nous déléguons en quelque sorte les
moyens de mieux nourrir de mieux
comprendre le monde où d'autres
ce seront les préférences collectives
d'autres puissances qui le feront
les chinois sont en train de le faire
mais avec un autre modèle n'ont pas le
même modèle agro alimentaire que nous on
voit bien ils n'ont pas le même modèle
d'innovation de respect de la vie privée
et même les américains n'ont pas le même
modèle que nous on a les mêmes valeurs
sur certains sujets mais nous n'avons
pas les mêmes préférences collectives on
n'a pas le même rapport à l'égalité à la
solidarité collective nos sociétés ne
fonctionne pas pareil et si nous
européens et en particulier nous
françaises et français voulons choisir
notre avenir il est essentiel de gagner
cette bataille qui est une bataille en
quelque sorte pour l'indépendance et la
meilleure qualité de vie bâtir cet
humanisme du 21e siècle c'est donc mieux
comprendre mieux vivre mieux produit
alors pour y arriver il ya des objectifs
c'est le fruit de votre travail je ne
suis là que le notaire en quelque sorte
le dépositaire de ce qui a été fait en
essayant de lui donner une forme et et
est d'inscrire dans le câble que je
viens d'évoquer
d'abord mieux produire
mieux produire au fond c'est la question
qui nous est tous posé ce sont les
tensions qu'on voit dans nos sociétés
dans tous nos secteurs c'est de dire
plus personne d'entre nous ne met en
cause le fait que nous devons faire face
à un monde qui doit émettre de moins en
moins de carbone possible qui doit
réussir à de plus en plus respecter la
biodiversité et donc redevenir positifs
en biodiversité est neutre en carbone en
2050 ça notre grand objectif
et tout ça commence dès maintenant parce
que nos premiers objectifs concrets sont
en 2030
et donc c'est vraiment une série de
révolutions dans la capacité à produire
l'énergie à faire de l'industrie à nous
déplacer à nous organiser premier
objectif
l'objectif numéro un c'est faire en mer
j'ai émergé en france d'ici 2030 des
réacteurs nucléaires de petite taille
innovant avec une meilleure gestion des
déchets sur ce sujet
pourquoi le mettre en premier le premier
sujet c'est la production de l'énergie
pour produire de l'énergie en
particulier d'électricité nous avons une
chance et notre modèle historique
le parc installé
de nucléaire j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent sur l'opportunité de construire
de nouveaux réacteurs et sur la
stratégie puisqu'il ya d'abord un
travail que nous avons demandé avec le
premier ministre et la ministre à rte
continuera à avancer mais il faut bien
le dire le rappeler les 200000
françaises et français qui travaillent
dans le secteur du nucléaire c'est une
chance parce que c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être le pays en europe
qui est parmi ceux qui émettent le moins
deux tonnes par co2 par électricité
produite
nucléaire par qu'hydro et notre base
installée
nous devons ré investir pour être à la
pointe de l'innovation de rupture dans
ce secteur ça passe par une série de
familles technologiques m'appartient pas
ici de l'est de les trancher est celle
ci ne sont pas en quelque sorte
exclusive des choix industriels qu'on
doit faire aussi à plus court terme sur
à la fois le nucléaire et les énergies
non renouvelables mais nous devons
absolument nous préparer à des
technologies de rupture et de
transformation profonde sur le nucléaire
la promesse de ce qu'on appelle les
small m'sila reactors qui sont les
petits réacteurs beaucoup plus modérée
bon plus sûr parce que la sûreté est un
point clé du débat sur le nucléaire les
technologies pour mieux gérer nos
déchets certaines sur lesquels nous
commençons à avancer certaines que nous
n'imaginons même pas avec là aussi un
travail fait par nos organismes de
recherche qui pour certains sont déjà
très avancés par nos grands industriels
historiques et par aussi d des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire des
start up et des pme françaises qui sont
en train de proposer des innovations de
rupture en la matière
pour le riz parvenir nous devons ouvrir
le jeu de manière totalement inédite et
nous sommes prêts à y investir un
milliard d'euros d'ici 2030 en
commençant très vite avec des premiers
projets très clair et donc là il faut
lancer plusieurs projets sur des
familles technologiques différentes mais
essayer d'avancer pour accélérer sur ce
volet
c'est absolument clé parce qu'on sait
qu'on continuera à avoir besoin de cette
technologie est au fond on doit traiter
de sujets clés améliorer toujours et
encore la sûreté en baissant les coûts
et réduire les déchets qui est un point
clé quand on parle de nucléaire deuxième
objectif
devenir le leader de l'hydrogène vert en
2030 là je le dis en l'assumant
totalement je pense ce fait partie
vraiment dans des secteurs où nous
pouvons être leader c'est une vraiment
une filière dans l'énergie où nous
pouvons encore le faire parce que nous
avons des atouts on a un premier atout
c'est encore une fois le nucléaire
pour produire de l'hydrogène il faut de
l'électricité parce qu'il faut faire de
l'électoralisme et beaucoup d'élèves que
d'ingénieurs donc j'ai l'impression de
dire des gens qui savent beaucoup mieux
que moi comment ça marche mais je le dis
pour ce soit clair parce que sinon on
perd de vue de nos débats donc on a
besoin de faire de l' électrolyse sa
consomment beaucoup d'électricité
si on produit de l'hydrogène
en utilisant du énergies fossiles ça
sert à rien
on peut produire on va produire de
l'hydrogène en important des
renouvelables mais aujourd'hui compte
tenu de l'électrification des mobilités
que l'europe de toute façon à décider
pour elles mêmes il n'est pas vrai qu'on
aura une énorme produit on n'aura jamais
en europe suffisamment de production de
renouvelables pour faire nos grandes
électrolyse et produire de l'hydrogène
vert et donc il en fait de grandes
stratégies de production d'hydrogène
vert il ya une stratégie qui consiste à
aller faire les oem les énergies non
renouvelables pardon pour faire lé
électrolyse très loin et réimporter
d'hydrogène ainsi produite un peu comme
on fait avec le gaz liquéfié il ya une
deuxième stratégie qui va être le coeur
de la nôtre non fera les 2 qui va être
de d'essayer d'en produire beaucoup chez
nous parce qu on a la possibilité de
faire de l'électro liste très décarbonés
et donc ça c'est une énorme chance c'est
ce qui nous permettra d'être en leader à
côté de ça on a de la très bonne
recherche on a des très bons acteurs air
liquide et quelques autres industriels
et on a un tissu de start-up
d'équipementiers d'entrepreneurs
d'innovateur qui sont prêts à y aller et
sont organisés et donc ce que nous
devons faire absolument sur l'hydrogène
c'est ne pas répéter les erreurs que
nous avons faites sur les énergies
renouvelables on a trop peu investi sur
l'offre et la capacité à développer
notre filière on l'a laissé filer on
doit développer notre offre industrielle
dans l'hydrogène et donc investir
massivement dans cette filière est donc
tout ça nous permettra de décarbonés
notre industrie d'alimenter nos camions
nos bus nos trains nos avions
ce qui est une voix absolument
formidable ce qui fait que d'ici à 2030
la france doit pouvoir compter sur son
sol au moins deux gigas factory
d'électrolyseurs et produira massivement
de l'hydrogène et l'ensemble des
technologies utiles à son utilisation
en parallèle de cette deuxième grand
objectif
nous aurons aussi un objectif
d'investissement de plus de 500 millions
d'euros dans les technologies de rupture
dans les énergies non renouvelables
particulier éoliennes terrestres et en
mer et photovoltaïque parce que la
stratégie d'investissement dans les
énergies non renouvelables est un point
clé pour l'innovation de rupture c'est
ce triptyque si vous voulez nucléaire
hydrogène
et énergie non renouvelable par ses
innovations de rupture qui nous
permettra de produire différemment de
l'énergie et d'électricité et de
commencer à contribuer justement un ce
monde où on produit mieux et décarbonée
nous avons comme vous le voyez des vrais
leviers on a des vrais avantages
historiques mais il faut accepter d'y
mettre les investissements que je viens
d'évoquer pour être atteindre ses
objectifs
troisième objectif décarbonés notre
industrie
décarbonés notre industrie qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que à côté de
la production de l'électricité on a de
toute façon ce que font nos grands
industriels et ils sont et c'est normal
des émetteurs de co2 par leurs activités
quotidiennes dans notre stratégie pour
2030 nous nous sommes engagés à baisser
entre 2015 et 2030 5,2 entre 2015 pardon
et 2030 35% de nos émissions dans le
secteur
c'est comme vous le voyez un point
important c'est un effort colossal bc 35
% les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par rapport à 2015 pour 2030 c'est une
révolution productif
on est en 2021 on a fait 4 %
donc c'est simple on ne va pas fermer
ses usines
parce que je ne serai pas cohérent est
ce que je vous ai dit sur l'indépendance
productive
donc nous devons massivement investir
pour les aider à décarbonée ce sera un
investissement public et privé mais sans
un investissement public c'est
impossible c'est insoutenable si
l'europe ne conduit pas cette stratégie
sa base productive ira produire de
l'autre côté du monde et donc toute la
stratégie européenne que nous avons
commencé à lancer est une stratégie qui
vise à accompagner les investissements
du privé pour décarbonés donc changer
complètement le processus industriel
m un mécanisme d'ajustement aux
frontières pour pénaliser les
industriels hors europe qui n'auraient
pas fait ces réformes et essayer de
bâtir transition climatique et
compétitivité
productive et industriels la présidence
française de l'union européenne nous
permettra tout cas nous nous battrons
pour cela de faire avancer l'agenda sur
le mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières
mais en parallèle de sa nous devons tous
accéléré sur la décarbonation nos
industries
c'est une stratégie qui est poursuivie
au niveau européen mais chaque pays
portent aussi et qui est extrêmement
onéreuses les montants sont énormes pour
chaque site industriel
l'allemagne vient d'annoncer sa
stratégie c'est la même chose que nous
lançons aujourd'hui de la même manière
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
complètement transformé nos grandes
aciéries nos grandes cimenteries pour
leur permettre de continuer à produire
d'ici à dix ans en réduisant leurs
émissions de co2
acier ciment produits chimiques qui sont
les carburants de toutes les autres
industries sonder la base de notre tissu
industriel on ne peut pas les perdre
mais on doit continuer de les produire
en baissant beaucoup plus rapidement les
choses cette stratégie décarbonation
elle est conclue donc ce sont des
investissements massifs de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros par sites
industriels
c'est évidemment la préservation de
plusieurs milliers d'emplois industriels
sur chacun de ces sites mais c'est la
clé pour qu'ils ne partent pas à l'autre
bout du monde en parallèle de cela notre
stratégie de décarbonation se complète
par la digitalisation et la robotisation
de notre industrie qui est aussi un
point clé vous l'avez rappelé sa femme
d'eric sanchez tout à l'heure mais on a
commencé avec france relance à le faire
on va accélérer avec justement le la
stratégie france 2030 de véritablement
digitalisées robotisé pour là aussi
aller vers une décarbonation notre
industrie au total ce sont plus de 8
milliards d'euros qui seront investis
pour atteindre justement c'est ses trois
premiers objectifs donc de décarbonation
de notre industrie et de financement de
d'un nouveau mix électrique et
d'innovation dans la production
d'électricité
reprendre le contrôle donc et et
produire mieux comme je l'évoquais c'est
aussi répondre industriellement aux
défis de nos modes de transport et c'est
pour ça que le quatrième objectif pour
moi est de pouvoir produire en france à
l'horizon 2030 près de deux millions de
véhicules électriques et hybrides
alors cet objectif qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on
le voit bien toujours la même ligne
directrice
nous voulons continuer de produire nous
croyons dans l'industrie mais nous
savons que nous devons continuer de ré
nos émissions c'est ce qu'on fait depuis
plusieurs années on doit pour cela
continuer de convertir ce qu'on appelle
notre parc automobile et donc réussir à
faire que les vieux véhicules polluants
soient remplacés par des nouveaux
véhicules ou électriques ou hybrides ou
même de dernière génération qui polluent
beaucoup moins mais il faut là aussi
appuyé cette stratégie qui se complète
par une stratégie de transport collectif
de nouvelles formes de déplacement d'une
stratégie industrielle
ce que nous ne voulons pas nous grande
nation de l'automobile devenir la nation
qui roulera le plus vert avec des
voitures qui ne sont plus produites chez
nous ça n'a aucun sens de faire ça
soyons le site sur nous mêmes les trente
dernières années ont été cruels pour
l'industrie automobile française
c'est le fruit d'erreurs de politique
industrielle c'est le fruit de stratégie
non coopératifs entre les acteurs de
l'industrie eux mêmes ils ont une énorme
responsabilité dans cette situation et
c'est le fruit d'une d'un choix qui a
été longtemps le choix français d'une
sous compétitivité industrielle c'est
simple quand on décide qu'on fait tous
payés par le facteur travail qu' on ne
rémunère pas bien le capital ont sous
investis